dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly failure so many of
you were sharing the previous episode
for the first time I just couldn't keep
up and write a kind message to every
single one of you but I'm trying my best
it really means a lot and again just
thanks so much for sharing so delighted
to see that people are coming in
checking out the series and expressing
that they liked it the feedback has been
absolutely insane you fellow scholars
seem to love the show quite a bit and it
really makes my day it's also fantastic
to see that there is a hunger out there
for science people want to know more on
what is happening inside the labs that's
really amazing thank you and let us
continue together on our scholarly
journey
3d printing is a technique to create
digital objects in real life it has come
a long way in the last few years there
has been excellent work done on
designing deformable characters
mechanical characters and characters of
varying elasticity you can even scan
your teeth and print copies of them and
these are just a few examples of a
multitude of things that you can do with
3d printing however this technology is
mostly focused on the geometry itself
colored patterns that people call
textures
still remains a challenge and we only
have very rudimentary technology to do
them so check this out this is going to
be an immersive experience hydrographic
printing on 3d surfaces is a really
simple technique you place a film in
water use a chemical activator spray on
it and shove the object in the water so
far so good
however since these objects start
stretching the film the technique is not
very accurate it only helps you putting
repetitive patterns on these objects
computational hydrographic printing is a
technique that simulates all of these
physical forces that are exerted on the
film when your desired object is
immersed into the water then it creates
a no image map taking all of these
distortions into account and this image
you can print with your home inkjet
printer the results will be really
accurate close to indistinguishable from
the digitally designed object the
technique also supports multiple
emergence that helps putting textures on
a non planar object with multiple sites
to be colored so as you can see 3d
printing is improving at a rapid pace
there's tons of great research going on
in this field it is a technology that is
going to change the way we live our
daily lives in ways that we cannot even
imagine yet and what would you print
with this do you have any crazy ideas
let me know in the comment section and
for now thanks for watching and I'll see
you next time